will the person who is high at work
please step
forward I'm going to start off with
Sophia we just had like really great
conversations but you just seemed like
very like mellow and even though that
could be something I just felt like you
were keeping Pace with it my next that I
don't think is high even though you
really did like the most amazing
performance as Mia couldn't be Marie
because Marie is working really hard on
this right now I didn't think it was ran
just something in my gut said it
couldn't be perfect sweet ran but Diana
I just thought you gave me that Vibe and
that sense Diana I think you're high at
work will the person who is high at work
please step
forward
no well done well done all of you sorry
j what's up you did a great job thank
you yeah